[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL MAGRO: So
welcome, everyone,
to a high-performance computing
session on Google Cloud.
My name is Bill Magro.
I am chief technologist for
high-performance computing
at Intel.
And I have the pleasure to
have with me today Peter
McShane from Appsbroker and
Bill Nitzberg from Altair.
They're in the corners and
we'll be working through this
together.
So what we plan to cover
today in this session
is I'm going to talk
about what Intel
is doing to power
HPC in the cloud
through our CPUs and our
activities working closely
with Google and
with the ecosystem.
But that's not enough.
And so we're going to
transition, then, to Bill.
And he's going to talk to you
about how Altair is working
to really make it easy to get
access to HPC in the cloud
by delivering
appliances, essentially
a PaaS layer, an access to
the applications that matter.
And then finally,
Peter's going to tell you
about a center of excellence
that we've put together
that's going to make
it a lot easier for you
to come and experience
HPC in the cloud
and do it with very low risk
and low cost to understand how
to take advantage
of the value we're
going to talk about today.
So let's dive right in.
So first of all, I'd
like to just talk
about our collaboration
with Google.
We have a longstanding--
about 15 year--
collaboration with Google.
And it started with them
providing feedback and helping
us shape the features
in our processors.
Over the years, we've delivered
six generations of custom CPUs
to Google.
And they were, in
fact, the first
to offer our latest processor,
Generation Platform Skylake,
also known as the Xeon
scalable processor family.
So it's very exciting to have
so much innovation in the cloud
and the earliest access.
And as you just
heard in the keynote,
and it was announced
recently, we're
now going to be
launching instances
with Google that actually use
Intel's Optane data center
memory, Optane DC, to give
very, very high capacity at much
lower cost for in-memory
workloads that demand that.
And so if you want to go over
to Raejeanne Skillern's session,
our cloud computing
GM, she's going
to be talking a lot more
about that in the next hour.
Look up the Intel session.
So Intel Xeon processors are at
the heart of the Google Cloud.
Obviously performance
is foundational.
And there's a lot that we've
put into our latest generation
Skylake to drive performance.
I'll tell you about
that later and show
you some of the results.
In terms of security, your
data security is paramount.
And Intel processors
have things such as
the AES-NI instructions,
which actually accelerate
the encryption/decryption
calculations and computations
that protect your data.
That's an example of
something that's in our CPUs
and always advancing to
give you high performance
and high security.
And finally, the virtualization
features in our processors
are really sitting underneath
a lot of the capability of both
the security and the
flexibility and the agility that
allows you to
share, essentially,
a common resource in the cloud
and do it safely and securely.
So clicking down a level into
high-performance computing,
I'd like to talk about
what HPC is first.
Sometimes you talk to people
and they're new to HPC.
Sometimes they have a
very different definition.
At Intel, we think of HPC
as an activity that really
has three characteristics.
The first one is the purpose
of the calculation is actually
to gain some insight.
You're trying to
learn something.
There's an intellectual product.
The second characteristic is it
has to be a demanding workload.
It's not low-performance
computing.
This is high-performance
And the third
characteristic, which
I think is really important,
is when you appropriately
apply more resources
to the problem,
you actually get a
more valuable result.
So think of one of these
examples like weather
forecasting.
You can do a weather
forecast on your phone,
but you get a 12-hour
forecast and maybe 30 days.
It has zero value.
But if you can run that
thing in three hours
and now determine
that something's
going to happen you need
to evacuate some people
or change your
plans, it can have
tremendous value, financial
value and just personal value.
And those examples,
there are many of them
across many fields that do
high-performance computing.
And it may be surprising to you
but we think of data analytics
and machine learning, a
lot of that, actually,
is a high-performance
computing workload.
And if you apply those
three tests, you'll see why.
So why are people
thinking about the cloud
for high-performance computing?
Some people think it's
a bit of an oxymoron.
High-performance computing is
about supercomputers, right?
Well, if you go to any
supercomputing site, what
you'll find is they have
some very large applications
and workloads that are
driving the characteristics
and the size of the machine.
But they have many, many smaller
workloads that could actually
run somewhere else.
So it's still HPC.
Not every workload needs
that machine, necessarily.
Those machines, though, tend
to be completely full, 100%
utilization.
And there's always a backlog.
And as soon as the
queue gets shorter,
engineers, scientists,
whoever's using that thing
are putting more jobs in.
So there's always
this pent-up demand.
And so one of the main reasons
people are looking to the cloud
is because some
of their workloads
can run well in
the cloud and they
can manage those demand surges.
And by taking some of the
workloads that maybe aren't
demanding the
on-premise resources
and putting them in the
cloud, they actually
make their on-premise
system even more valuable
while it stays full.
There's also getting
access to new technologies,
like I mentioned, earliest
access to Skylake in the cloud.
And also R&D collaboration,
think of teams
all around the world.
Rather than shipping
data back and forth,
we take advantage of
the tremendous network
that Google Cloud
has and it enables
people to collaborate
much more easily than they
have been able to in the past.
So how do you decide
what workloads
should fit in the Cloud?
There's really two
characteristics.
The first one is, do
you trust the Cloud?
And I would argue
that in the past
people have felt that the Cloud
maybe wasn't as secure and as
safe as keeping things at home.
I think those
perceptions are changing.
Some of the best security in
the world is in the Cloud.
So there's this
boundary of public Cloud
that's rising as
a result of that.
In terms of technical
characteristics, as I said,
there's a wide range of
workloads that run in HPC.
And any of them could
run on a dedicated HPC
system or a supercomputer.
But many of them
over on the left
where they don't necessarily
need to scale as far,
they don't need
as tight coupling
for message passing, which
is the predominant way
that high-performance
computing applications run,
these are a great fit.
And so you see in industries
like finance and genomics,
that's where things start.
Or in manufacturing, I
showed them on the boundary
where some of the
early calculations
to do design studies
are done in the Cloud.
And final studies for
noise vibration harshness,
combustion, car crash
simulation, and safety
are run, still, on a
traditional HPC system.
So finding the right
workloads is key,
and putting those in the Cloud.
So behind HPC in the Cloud
and behind the Google Cloud
we have the Intel Xeon
scalable processor family.
This is our latest
generation, codenamed Skylake.
And we drove a
lot of innovations
into this processor
specifically to meet
the needs of high-performance
computing workloads.
They have very broad
benefits, but HPC
was one of the main drivers.
An example is moving from the
previous generation's Ring
architecture to
connect the cores
to a dual two-dimensional mesh.
There's also tremendous
cache enhancements,
the addition of
AVX-512 instructions,
that allows us to do twice as
many FLOPS per clock tick--
Floating Point Operations.
We increase the memory
bandwidth by a factor of two
over the previous generation.
And finally, we increased
the number of cores
and the efficiency
of hyperthreading.
And as a result, people
are able to run much more
dense calculations
on a single CPU.
So you're seeing many more
virtual machines, virtual CPUs,
inside of a VM now are possible.
So where are these available?
Google's been tremendously
aggressive in getting these
out.
And so I think this slide
is already out of date
since we made it
just a few weeks ago.
There were 13 regions.
Google is adding Skylake
instances all around the world.
So if you want to use
these, all you have to do
is say the minimum CPU
and specify this family.
In fact, Bill will talk about
that a bit in his section.
And you can get access
to these and try it out
and see how well they
do for your own workload
because at the end of the
day, that's what matters.
But I do want to show you
some examples from some
of our customers and
what they're saying.
I think Decartes Lab is
a really interesting,
interesting company.
They are mining 1 petabyte of
satellite imagery from NASA
from the last 40 years
to look at what's
going on and out of
the satellite data,
correlate it to the history of
the food supply in the world
and using it to
predict crop yields.
This impacts the financial
services markets.
It impacts food security
around the world.
This is an application of
high-performance computing,
machine learning, and
obviously very, very big data.
And they've just, in this
move to the latest generation,
saw a 40% uptick almost
in their performance.
And you can see
other examples where
people are seeing
almost 2x, especially
in the life sciences area, the
biotech companies at the right.
So Descartes actually
has a session tomorrow.
If you want to hear more
about their experience,
you can go look at it.
So a lot of this
performance does come to you
quite naturally if you've
modernized your code.
But I do want to put
one caveat out there
and say, if you haven't
modernized your code,
you're just counting
on the processor
to make things faster,
you may be missing out.
So this is an example
from financial services
of a binomial tree
options calculation.
And you can see there's a 130x
performance difference over
the seven years that comes from
someone who actively optimized
the code versus
someone who didn't.
So you need to thread your code.
You need to vectorize your code.
You need to work with
the Intel compilers that
unleash the performance
of this processor.
Otherwise, you could be leaving
100x performance on the table.
This is a synthetic
benchmark, but we see it
in real applications, as well.
So it is work.
But we have things to
help you out with that.
So what does Intel
do to help you?
We're talking about
modernizing your code.
Well, the first
thing we need to do
is provide a
development methodology
for your high-performance
computing applications
that allows you to
understand where
you're leaving
performance on the table
and then go chase it down.
So some things we
recommend, first one, out
of this Parallel Studio XE
is use optimized libraries.
These have been hand-tuned
for the latest processors that
are out there today.
They're launched
with the processors.
So if you're using
math libraries,
you're getting the performance.
Many, many applications
in HPC do that.
The second one is compile.
Our compilers are
updated well ahead
of the release of a
processor and allow
you to actually update
your application.
It'll still run on
previous generations.
But will be optimized
for the new generation,
be ready to go
when it comes out.
We have analysis
tools, again, that
point you to not only where
you're leaving performance
on the table, but
also tell you how
you can extract that performance
by making recommendations
around vectorization,
recommendations
around threading, and
even projecting for you
the type of performance that
you could get our advisor tool.
And finally, our
VTune tool shows
you the results of your
analysis and whether or not
you got the performance
you expected.
And if not, why not?
By using the hardware counters
that exist in our processors.
And there's some very
advanced analysis techniques.
And finally,
performance is nothing
if your application
isn't correct.
And anyone who's done
parallel programming
knows that multi-threading,
vectorization,
if you do them incorrectly,
you can get the wrong result.
So we have a whole
suite of tools
that analyze and will help you
find those types of problems
automatically, which are
tremendous productivity
boosters.
So this is exactly what we
recommend for on-prem systems.
It's exactly what you
need to do in the Cloud.
So we've put a lot of
effort in with Google
to make sure that these tools
run and run well in the Cloud.
So please check out
the Parallel Studio XE
if you're going to be running
applications in the Cloud
that you write yourself.
So last thing I want to say
before I hand it over to Bill
is, I've talked about CPUs.
I've talked about
the motivations.
But there's a big
distance between coming up
from the bottom and
having the infrastructure
interfaces that you get
through Google Cloud.
And what HPC users
and HPC applications
expect coming from the top
and the link between those two
worlds to make it
possible for you
to continue using
your on-prem resources
but to put those same
applications, perhaps
with different input sets,
in the Cloud is consistency.
So Intel has been
working with the industry
for over a decade to document a
standard cluster architecture.
And it's been
adopted very broadly.
Altair's been one of our
great partners in this.
And their appliances
actually implement
this and as a result
are very compatible,
not only with their
own applications,
but from applications
across the industry.
So with that, I'd like to
introduce Bill Nitzberg, who
will take you through some
of those usability things
and making HPC
work in the Cloud.
Thanks, Bill.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL NITZBERG: And now I
got to say, "Thanks, Bill."
Let me just start by
telling you that I believe,
we believe at Altair, that
HPC improves people's lives.
And you've heard from Bill
about the different places.
But when I think about
high-performance computing,
I think about making
child safety seats safer,
making airplanes
lighter to save fuel,
making my cell phone not
break when I drop it.
It's about making
people's lives better.
It's why I'm here.
It's why I do what I do.
It's why I really love
working at Altair.
And a tiny bit
about Altair, we're
kind of unique in
that I'm going to talk
about the middleware layer
which is trying to make HPC
more accessible and more easy.
That's PBS Works.
I'm going to talk about that.
That's where I live in Altair.
But Altair also has
two other groups that
are actually bigger than mine.
One makes applications,
physics applications,
that actually do
high-performance computing.
So the folks who are
actually designing
a new outside of a phone or
something or a new car bumper
or something will use
those applications.
And then we actually
have a team of people
around the world, hundreds of
people around the world, who
are just engineers
actually using these tools,
using our middleware,
doing stuff.
It's this fantastic
feedback loop.
We have openings if you
want to-- nevermind.
So PBS Works is really software
for high-performance computing
that makes high-performance
computing sort of more natural,
more easy.
And I'll give you a
couple of examples.
And I have a couple of videos.
So we focus on making
things sort of easier
for administrators and
managers to control
high-performance computing.
And that's both giving
visibility about what's
going on but also sort of
setting things up, doing
all the nitty gritty
that you have to do,
connecting to clusters, but
also sort of connecting up
into a cloud, or actually
just running in the Cloud.
I'll say more about that.
But we also focus
on making things
easier for actual
engineers and researchers
when they're using stuff.
And I'll show you what the
vision looks like for that.
And then finally, we have--
and that's Altair Access
is the name of the tool.
And then we have a
tool called PBS Pro,
which I won't really talk
about, which optimizes stuff
once it actually gets there.
Tiny bit more about Control.
So Control is the control center
that we put in front of it.
It's a GUI.
It's a web-based GUI for HPC
administrators that lets you--
single pane of glass.
It lets you configure,
deploy, monitor, handles
bursting for you, connecting
your private HPC supercomputer
up to something
like Google Cloud.
Gives you real time
monitoring, reporting.
Really nice feature that we've
added is a workload simulator.
And I don't have a demo of
this, so I'll just say it.
So one of the problems in
high-performance computing
is these are really
complicated systems.
Even if you're using--
even if you're all cloud,
it's a complicated
infrastructure
with a complicated workload.
And if you want to optimize
exactly what you're using
and how you're using it,
it's nice to be able to say,
hey, here's what I
did last quarter.
Could you tell me if I
changed a few things around,
if I used larger memory nodes,
how fast things would things
have got done?
Would we have had
faster turnaround?
So we have a simulator built
in that lets you ask and answer
that question.
And then cloudbursting.
On the Access side,
we really have
been trying to re-imagine
what engineers do.
So I'm a geek.
I'm a nerd.
And so I live in command line.
I'm happy to install Linux,
although I haven't done it
in many years.
But I'm happy to, really.
And what we found, though, is
that's great at the very, very
high end.
People really know
what they're doing.
They're experts.
But if you want to take
high-performance computing--
which, by the way, my definition
of high-performance computing
is taking computing up to the
absolute maximum performance
level you can.
Not quite just to where
it almost doesn't work,
but right up to the edge.
So performance is paramount.
And so at that level, you have
a lot of really smart people.
They don't mind
doing a lot of stuff.
But if you want to make that
available to other people
down lower, what we've found
is that the engineers of today
are not as happy doing all
the nitty gritty stuff.
And in fact, if you
can give an interface--
this is crazy.
I don't believe it, but
I actually believe it.
That sounds crazy.
If you could give an interface
that requires zero Linux shell
or zero little bits about IT,
you can actually attract, like,
100 times more people in
terms of just learning curve.
So if you can get nobody
to have to type ls or cp,
you actually get this
huge extra set of people.
And so that's our vision.
And let me just show you what
PBS Access, the vision for PBS
Access-- and I don't know
if this is going to work.
I should introduce this.
This is a Windows desktop
of how you might actually
access Google Compute
platform running
a high-performance
computing application.
And the video is really
a day in [INAUDIBLE]..
58 seconds in the
life of an engineer
to run a high-performance
application.
OK, so that we're going to
have to do from here, I think.
Let's see what we got.
Wow, I don't know how
to play the video.
Do we-- Andy, you got it?
No.
OK, we're going to go
to YouTube apparently.
But I really don't
have that screen.
Ah, there we go.
Wait.
I'm going to do this.
It's going to mess
everything up.
We're going to start
it from the beginning.
OK.
Regular desktop.
I'm a regular engineer.
Usually, I just have my
files in front of me.
I'm right-clicking on a file.
It actually gives me this
new option, Process With,
which basically means run some
high-performance computing.
I'm going to pick
Optistruct, which
is a structural engineering
optimization code.
That's it.
That right click is
everything I need to do.
You can see in the upper
right it's actually uploading
some files off to the
high-performance computing
system or a cloud.
It's actually submitting a
job for me automatically.
The little file icon actually
says, hey, stuff was uploading.
And hopefully by the time
I finish this sentence,
that little file icon will say,
everything is now downloaded.
No, OK.
OK, job has completed.
And it will automatically
bring those files back.
So what did I not do?
I didn't log in anywhere.
I didn't type any shell.
I didn't do anything.
And we're actually
doing some Google I/O.
And I don't know how
to get back to this.
Can we go back here?
No.
Wait, wait.
SPEAKER: Middle tab.
BILL NITZBERG: The which?
SPEAKER: On your browser.
The middle tab.
The one next to the--
that one.
BILL NITZBERG: Hey, hey.
OK.
Thank you.
There's going to be
two videos, sorry.
Awesome.
So the vision is basically
effectively nearly invisible
high-performance computing.
So that's going to
actually attract
a huge quantity of more
people who don't have access
to high-performance computing.
And that lets you get to
your local system or Cloud.
At Altair, like I said,
we have this broad range
of applications.
And one of the
things that you want
to do in high-performance
computing
is you want to perform
as fast as possible.
So these are physics
applications that do the work.
As in the end, one
of the nice things
about our partnership
with Intel,
we get access to
Intel processors.
And we can actually do
sorts of neat tests.
And we did one of those tests
with RADIOSS, a crash code,
and found that, actually, it
runs 1.8 times faster on Intel
Skylake.
There's two examples I'll
give of how you can actually
choose Intel Skylake because if
you want to get performance--
if you're doing high performance
computing, you want to.
So one is when you're creating
an instance on Google Cloud,
you can just pick
[? i1 ?] Skylake.
And for that, you're going
to actually get Skylake.
You'll get this
1.8 times faster.
But how do you actually get--
most high performance
computing today
is actually done in private
systems on supercomputers.
And even though it's
the most leading edge
newest work that
people are working on,
the organizations are a
little slow to adopt things.
So most of the work actually
still happens in-house
on private clusters.
And we're just
connecting the Cloud.
And the way that we're
connecting to the Cloud
is through cloud bursting.
If you haven't heard it
before, all that means
is building a hybrid system.
A lot of work's
happening locally.
When you have specific
work that fits,
you actually create an
instance on the cloud
to run that local work.
And with the PBS works tools,
we make that really seamless.
I'm going to skip this slide
in the interest of time here.
Let me show you how it's done.
And I'll just show
the second video,
which I'm going to
have trouble with,
which is why I'm
skipping a slide.
So this is the
last video I have.
And let me see if I
can do this by clicking
on the right-hand side here.
Let's see if this just works.
Ha, it works.
So with PBS works we actually
let you build an appliance
on the Cloud with a few clicks.
So this is the interface
inside of PBScloud.io,
which is the software as a
service version of PBS Control.
You just say, hey, I want
to build an appliance.
Say a few things
about what you want.
You pick Google compute
platform, because we're here.
You can pick the region
where you want to run.
And then, actually, for the
appliance, in this case,
we're building a
HyperWorks appliance.
You'll actually pick the kinds
of instances you want in here.
I'm actually picking
a 96 CPU instance,
so that will get me Skylake.
We automatically
fill in for you all
of this crazy stuff you
need in order to actually do
this administration stuff.
You can, of course, change
it because you have to.
And that's it.
The beautiful interface I showed
you on the Windows desktop
also is available
as a web interface.
It's just as beautiful
but maybe not as simple.
But if you want to submit
a job through the web
instead of through the desktop,
more or less the same thing.
You pick the
application you want.
You say, here's the file I want.
Fill in anything
that's not defaulted.
And click Submit.
You can actually get
a lot more access
through the web about what's
happening if you need to.
So you can actually find
out what's going on.
You can check the files
as they're running
on supercomputing center.
You can check the
files, actually,
if you burst into the
cloud, you can actually
see the files of the running
job while it's there.
You can get all sorts
of job attributes.
Perhaps one of the
very neat things
that you can do through
this interface--
I don't have my timing perfect--
is you can also do remote
visualization, which
means you can take
something like a Chromebook
here with no memory and you can
submit a job, a graphics job,
that's going to use, say,
256 gigabytes of memory
and all sorts of
huge, powerful stuff.
And you can say, please
run this job in the Cloud,
but I want you to stream
the bits back in my browser
so that I can actually do the
work no matter where I am.
And it's as simple as,
while I was talking,
what you saw there.
You just say, here's
what I want to run.
I want to run on the Cloud.
We do all the orchestration
behind the scenes.
We set everything up.
And you can run huge and
fantastic large-- yeah,
sorry about that, bicyclist--
fantastic, large
simulations, even
from a really small device.
And with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to the next speaker, Peter.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER MCSHANE: Come
on, let's give Bill
a big round of applause.
There's some exciting
technology we see here, folks.
Who would have
thought a year ago
we could even do
some of the things
that we're doing that is
possible that Bill Magro was
talking about in terms of HPC?
Some of the orchestration
tools the Bill from Altair
has just been telling us
in terms of orchestration
are incredible.
But I'm here to ask
a question and help
see how we can
answer that, which
is, given all this amazing
technology, why is so
little of it still being used?
Less than 10% of this
great cloud technology
is being used at the moment
by people that require HPC.
And I have a personal
interest in this,
as well, in that
once upon a time,
I was doing a lot of
electromagnetic linear
induction research.
And one of my biggest
frustrations was waiting.
And how, in today's
environments,
can we afford to wait?
And that's something that
we really need to solve,
and really need
to solve quickly.
I think there's
a lot of business
people in the audience
that don't really
realize what's possible.
And that's what we
want to help enable.
So I'm Peter McShane.
Good morning, everybody.
I represent a company
called Appsbroker.
And before we help
answer that question,
let's tell you a bit
more about Appsbroker.
Appsbroker is an
extraordinary organization.
We are the biggest Google
practice in Europe.
The biggest.
We've got 150 staff
spread across the UK,
spread across Romania.
And usually we also have what
we call customer experience
offices in France, in the Alps.
And we own our own island where
we do customer collaboration
and team building.
So we do things
differently, so differently
that if you wanted to
spot an Appsbroker person,
just look for people wearing
these red jackets because we
were told it was cold
in San Francisco.
Man, we are sweating.
So yeah, very easy to spot.
And just to give you a sense
of what Appsbroker is all about
is for some of those who were
listening to the solutions
selling workshop, where we're
doing things differently
in financial services is that
we're helping apply regulation
or helping banks enable
method regulation
and opening up all sorts
of new data sources
they didn't know existed.
We're doing similar
things in retail,
in supply chain optimization
in the retail space.
But one of the things that
we're really excited about
is all this infrastructure the
Bill Magro is talking about.
How do we start creating
real-time innovation?
How do we start
getting results now?
And that's why one of the
things that we're doing now
is we've set up a partnership
with Intel and Google
to form what we call the Extreme
Cloud Center of Excellence.
Now, this is an amazing
facility with three
pioneering organizations
in Cloud coming together
to try and answer that question
that we talked about earlier.
Firstly, delivering
something that
is not just cheaper but faster,
and also way easier to consume.
Cheaper because Google
Cloud is currently
offering the lowest TCO in terms
of changing what is normally
in super compute a big CAPEX
expense into an OPEX expense
with some of the greatest
technology from Intel.
I mean, without a
doubt, Intel Xeon
scalable technology is some
of the best in industry
at the moment.
But what they are
doing, as well,
is Bill talked about
Parallel Studio and some
of the maths kernel
libraries, as well.
These are really making
it a bit easier to use.
But where we're putting
the wrapping on that
is trying to bring
people into this, people
in terms of Appsbroker
experts that
have been working with
Google for 12 years
on implementing Google Platform.
So we understand Google, but
leveraging the best of Intel
and Google resources, as well.
Now, why is that important?
Because one of the reasons
why a lot of the change
isn't happening is because
it's about creating
business awareness.
Business leaders don't
know what's possible.
It's also around creating
technical awareness,
helping people understand what
performance is really possible,
people that typically
have their own platforms.
And also it's very much around
creating a change in culture,
as well, one where
people are thinking
about using new features all
the time and not standalone,
static systems.
So we talked earlier
about extreme cloud.
Bill mentioned the use cases
in a number of industries.
And yes, right now, using
the Google Cloud Platform
for big companies
means you can do
far more processing, far more
analysis, far more simulations.
You can get really good
insights at very low cost.
The challenge you were hearing
from a lot of customers,
though, is, well, if we
start adopting the Cloud,
how are we going to have
a roadmap of innovation?
And that's something that Google
is answering with the Intel
relationship.
You heard today, or yesterday,
about the Apache Pass feature
set that's been put
onto the Intel platform.
And there's many, many
more things coming.
And what's great about Google is
they're adopting that quickly.
So that's a big tick.
The second thing,
though, we're hearing
from customers is, this is
great, but what about security?
Because despite the fact that
Google's whole Cloud platform
was built with security
as part of the DNA,
people don't really know
how to use it properly.
A lot of them have
system administrators
that haven't really had
the experience of deploying
and scaling Cloud yet.
A lot of them don't know
how to do sandboxing.
And a lot of them are also
concerned about latencies
because some of them have
very constrained systems
where the infrastructure needs
to be pretty close to the data.
So that's why we set up ECCoE.
ECCoE is a physical facility.
The first one we've
got is in the UK.
We're planning to put
dots all over the map.
And what it's doing is
allowing organizations
to really get a sense of the
power of the Google Cloud
Platform in terms of HPC.
Now, how we're
doing that is we're
not just providing access
to Google Cloud and people.
What we're doing is real hybrid
performance benchmarking.
What that means is we've got a
facility with an in-house Intel
on-premise platform as
well as the Google Cloud.
So customers can start seeing
which workloads make sense
to put in the Cloud and
which workloads makes sense
to leave on-prem.
Because we're not saying that
Google Cloud right now is
the answer to all the workloads.
There are some workloads,
there are many workloads,
that are very
sensitive that have
to be run on on-prem systems.
But this offers an opportunity
to really start testing
that in different environments.
What we also have is
partnerships with some
of the specialized ISVs.
So we talked about Altair.
And if you can wander down
to Moscone West to the
where the Intel stand
is, were actually
showing some of the work we
are doing with Altair and PBS
there.
And how can we start
optimizing orchestration?
How can we start doing it across
several different applications?
What you also get with
the ECCoE environment is
direct access to some of the
key staff in Appsbroker, Google,
and Intel, who are
currently looking at some
of the new feature
sets and really start
enabling sort of a
hybrid cloud environment,
start doing real sandboxing.
One of the cool things, as well,
is wherever we're learning,
we're turning those into tools.
So in terms of
orchestration, we're
looking at how we start doing
consistent deployment of VMs
and containers at scale,
which enables this.
We're also looking at
tools for cost management,
as well, because one of the
things that customers are
concerned about when
moving into the cloud
is how do I contain the cost?
How does this not
get out of control?
It's great that I'm
innovating at speed.
But how do I avoid this
getting out of control?
And that's the value that we're
providing as part of the ECCoE
environment.
Now in order to realize scale,
one of the things we recognize
is that you need to have a
proof of concept initially.
And we call our proof
of concept process Three
Steps to Extraordinary.
Now, what this does is
helps both business leaders
and technical folk
in organizations
get a sense of what the business
case is, get a sense of what
the benchmarking, what the
performance is, and also
what the roadmap should look
like for your organization.
So as part of that,
we've established
what we call the Appsbroker
blueprint, which really helps
work with you to get a sense
of exactly how your HPC is
performing at the moment.
And from that, moving that
into a workshop environment
within the ECCoE
environment where
we can start doing
some optioneering,
start not just doing whiteboards
in terms of what workload
should go in which place,
what kind of orchestration
is possible, but actually
testing that real time.
So now you have an opportunity
within a lab environment
to start sandboxing
properly across both on-prem
and off-prem.
Start trying different
types of orchestration.
And the results of these Three
Steps Extraordinary process
is effectively a
business case which
gives you the cost benefits,
gives you the performance
benefits, which
workloads perform,
which don't, and also
gives you a roadmap.
Now, that's pretty
critical for customers.
And in fact somebody that
we're working with live right
now is European hedge fund.
There is an immense demand in
buy-side financial services
in terms of quants to start
taking advantage of Google
Cloud, and a massive demand.
But one of the challenges
that they keep on facing
is, well, how do we
make this secure?
How do we start actually
using the capacity
in the right way for
different types of workloads?
You've got quants that
are doing algorithms
on significant amounts
of external data,
significant amounts of
internal data, who currently
are constrained to
develop new algorithms
or are constrained
because algorithms take
too long to run on systems.
This means millions of
dollars, millions of dollars,
for these organizations.
And so what we're
doing is working
with one of the
larger hedge funds
to look at, firstly, setting
up a hybrid data set up,
so mimicking what they need in
the future, which is probably
in a bit of an on-premise
as well as a cloud platform.
Start establishing
provisioning, helping
them to start
provisioning at scale,
both on-prem and off-prem.
Helping to do set-ups
and tear-downs
as quickly as possible.
Also, reproduce a third
party environment.
Bring the ISVs into the mix.
In the same way we talked
about Altair and crash testing,
we're going to do the
same in the quant space.
Bring everybody
into the environment
because we don't
know all the answers.
But if we bring
everybody in, we're
going to get the right answers.
And one of the things that
we're looking, as well,
with this particular fund is
how with the workload manager
you can start
allocating workloads
between different
types of environment.
And what's exciting is that the
moment people start recognizing
the potential is they
start looking at some
of the other Google products
such as TensorFlow and Cloud AI
and look at, well,
hey, we can use these
to create whole new models.
This is the exciting
thing about when
people start
culturally recognizing
the art of the possible
through this ECCoE environment.
And one of the other things
that we've helped the hedge fund
organizations is we showed
them our cost control
dashboard, which really
takes a view of what
your likely spend might be, and
starts notifying and messaging
people in terms of when
things may run out.
So it gives you control
over that spend, as well.
So in summary, I think we're
at an inflection point.
All this technology that Bill
and Bill spoke about earlier
is fantastic.
But it's really usable now.
And I think coming
back to the question I
asked at the beginning
of the presentation
is, why are you waiting?
Why are you waiting to innovate?
If you're running a design
business, if you need insights,
why are you waiting?
The time is now.
And certainly, if
you can make your way
down to the Intel
stand in Moscone West,
we'd love to talk to you.
We'd love to see how
we could potentially
do a proof of concept
with your organization
and start making this real.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]